these days the news is full of heavy
information so we thought we'd take a
break from that and share a bunch of
light fun facts in a segment called did
you know
so tarek and i will go back and forth
saying fun little facts that we think
you might not know are you ready tarek
yep
okay so i'll go first
did you know that polar bear's fur isn't
white it's see-through and reflects the
light making it seem white
how cool yeah are they a predator or an
optical illusion they're both
did you know that bats are the only
mammal that can fly oh if you don't
count superman
hey tarik did you know that the most
violent incident in the civil rights era
is something most of us have never heard
of on the campus of south carolina state
university in 1968 state troopers shot
28 student protesters and there was no
formal investigation
did you know that
no
um
i didn't did you know that canada is
actually south of detroit
i'm gonna have to look at a map
did you know that one quarter of the
first 33 black men elected to georgia's
legislature were threatened
beaten or killed by white protesters
no
um did you know that the first
footprints on the moon will be there for
a million years cool
did you know that there's a long and
rich history of black journalism in this
country but there are about 25 black
owned papers from the late 18 and early
1900s that have no remaining copies and
did you know that the reason for that is
usually because the newspaper offices
were destroyed by angry white mobs did
you know did you know did you know that
um
these are supposed to be fun facts right
yeah
because it seems like mine are fun but
yours are truly terrifying really i
didn't notice that how about this did
you know that more people visit france
than any other country in the world
i didn't it must be because paris is the
city of love what i don't love though is
the fact that wilberforce college the
first university owned and operated by
african americans has been burned to the
ground by racial terrorists twice
roger williams university in tennessee
was also burned down two times before it
finally closed and it's not just
colleges in 1910
white rioters burned down every black
school in new orleans and the city
didn't have a black school for 17 years
that is not fun but it is a fact
okay uh but i thought this was gonna be
like a fun light-hearted segment derek
as black people living in america we
don't have the luxury of being
lighthearted
[Laughter]
now that's a fact
this has been did you know
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you